- Having trans friends
is like having friends.
- You were shaking.
- I was shaking.
I was sweating.
- You were shaking at the table,
and then I knew, I was
like oh yeah, here we go.
- And then I just came out and told you.
- She's not turning back.
- Yeah.
- I got her, I got here.
- I've seen a confidence come out of you
that I didn't see in the beginning.
This just brought you
out to a whole new level.
- I think so, too. (laughs)
- (laughs)
- My impression of you
was you're tall, skinny,
and pretty.
- I just
- You still haven't told me, hey.
- Yeah, I haven't even
told you 'til today.
- 'Til right now.
Let's do it right now.
Ready?
- Okay, let's go.
- Catherine.
- Hey.
- I'm a woman of trans experience.
- That's beautiful.
You make me want to cry.
- You, I don't know if I should say this,
but you were a different name at the time.
- I did have a different name at the time.
- Which I thought was awesome,
but I also think that your
name is equally awesome.
- I don't think it changes what I think
about you as a friend.
I think our relationship
is built on the moments
we've had together.
- So, what do you feel is the difference
having me as a friend being trans
versus when you're with you cis friends?
- When you were transitioning,
I felt a little more protective.
For a long time now, you've just been
like one of my girlfriends.
- I want you guys to see me as me,
and you still treated me
like on of your girlfriends.
- You are (laughs).
- And talked about boy issues.
- Yeah.
- And stuff like that.
- It was too many boy issues (laughs).
- Were you scared that
I would get attacked
in the men's restroom
when I was still using it?
- There was just a
point where I rather you
just come in the same restroom as me.
- I enter any men's room going,
oh please, I hope nobody notices
that I'm going into the stall
and realizes that I
might not be cis gender.
- I never saw us here today,
and so I kind of.
- Really?
What did you see?
Honestly, I didn't even
think I'd live this long.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- See, that's crazy.
- I hope you don't lose faith in humanity.
Somehow, it will change,
and keep being your fabulous self
because girls like me who look up to you
for their definition of what can be sexy.
- You're sexy too, though (laughs).
- I don't even know if I'd
have had the guts to transition
if it wasn't for people
like you so early on
who helped and reinforced that
I am worthy of being loved.
- In the beginning, you were sort of this
masculine figure in my life.
That's something that I always appreciated
'cause you were just there
to be like my brother.
- It's what you do for family.
- You kind of introduced me to a world
and a culture that I
wasn't aware of before.
I think that I've become a more richer
and a richer person.
Yeah.
- Awesome.
- Right?
- Definitely pushes me to want to be like,
be the woman, I guess, that I want to be.
- Ahh!
- Through you (laughs).
Is that weird?
Yeah.
- That's amazing.
- It's true, it's true.
- It's true
- I love you.
- I love you, mama, come on.
- Thank you.
- Thank you for sharing.
- Can we hug now?
- Yes.
- Come here.
- Yeah.
- I love you, pretty.
- The only really upsetting thing
about having trans friends, I will say,
and I thought about this as well
is they are all far more
attractive that I am,
and it's really infuriating.